So I want to tell you about a book
today.
The book is called the Gulag
Archipelago.
You Ready?
The book is called the Gulag Archipelago
and it's by a Russian author.
Soviet arts are deemed Aleksandr
Solzhenitsyn,
who was in the Gulag archipelago
concentration camp system for a very
long time.
He had a very hard life.
He was on the
Russian front when the Germans invaded
the Soviet Union in the early stages of
World War II.
Now Hitler and Stalin had signed a
nonaggression pact.
Um,
okay.
And Hitler invaded the Soviet Union
anyway.
And from what I've been able to
understand,
the Soviets had prepared an invasion
force for Europe at that point,
but we're not concerned with having to
defend their territory.
And so they were caught completely
unawares by Hitler's move.
And the conditions on the Russian front
were absolutely dreadful.
And soldier in Hudson was a soldier on
the Russian front and
he wrote some letters to one of his
friends,
which were intercepted,
complaining about the lack of
preparation and,
and using bitter dark humor to describe
the situation.
And
the consequences of that was that he was
thrown into a work camp.
The Soviet system relied on work camps.
And so those were large labor camps of
people who were essentially enslaved,
many of whom were worked to death,
often froze to death,
working in conditions that were so
dreadful that they're virtually
unimaginable.
Solzhenitsyn spent a very large number
of years in these camps,
uh,
sometimes in a more privileged camp
because he was an educated man and
sometimes in worst camps.
He also,
uh,
developed cancer,
later and wrote a book about that called
Cancer Ward,
which is a brilliant book.
Um,
so he had a very hard life.
There's,
there's just no way around that to be on
the front and then to be in a
concentration camp and then to have
cancer.
That's pretty rough.
Now he wrote the Gulag archipelago.
He wrote a book called one day in the
life of Ivan Denisovich first that was
published in the early 1960s when there
was a brief thaw.
Stalin was pretty much out of the
picture by the end of the 1950s.
There's some indication that he was
murdered by Khrushchev and a cruise ship
became a premier of the Soviet Union
afters stolen and there's some
indication perhaps that Stellan was
either murdered by Khrushchev and a set
of his cronies or when he was very ill
just before he died was not helped at
least by wasn't provided with any
medical attention because of the
intervention of Khrushchev and his
cronies.
Now there was some indication as well at
that point that Stalin who was an
absolute absolutely barbaric in every
possible way you could imagine was
planning to start a third World War and
he was certainly capable of doing such
things because he had already imprisoned
or killed tens of millions of people.
Now
just after Stalin died,
there was a bit of a thought in the
Soviet Union with regards to internal
repression.
In the early 1960s Solzhenitsyn
published a book called one day in the
life of Ivan Denisovich,
which was a story about one day in the
life.
His life really inside one of these so
called Gulag archipelago camps.
Now he called it the Gulag archipelago
because in our compelling go is a chain
of islands.
And so Solzhenitsyn likened the work
camp system in the Soviet Union,
which was made up of isolated camps
distributed across the entire state.
He likened that to a series of islands
and enhance,
hence the metaphor.
And one day in the life of Ivan
Denisovich was one of the first
publications released in the Soviet
Union that dared make public what had
happened inside these camps,
at least initially.
Now that thought didn't last very long,
but that book had a tremendous effect.
It's a short book,
it's worth reading.
Um,
after that he spent,
he wrote a number of other books,
which are also great.
He's a great literary figure in the same
category I would say as Tolstoy or
Dostoevsky,
which is like really saying something,
you know,
those,
those two are perhaps the greatest
literary figures.
Whoever lived with the possible
exception of Shakespeare.
He wrote this book called the Gulag
Archipelago,
which is published in three volumes,
each of which has about 700 pages long.
Um,
the first one details the origin of the
oppressive Soviet system,
at least in part under Lenin.
And then it's full fledged
implementation understanding and the
deaths of,
while Solzhenitsyn estimated the deaths
in internal repression in the Soviet
Union at something approximating 60
million between 1919 in 1959.
Now that doesn't count the death toll in
the second world war,
by the way.
Now people have disputed those figures,
but there certainly in the tens of
millions in the low inbounds are
probably 20 million and the high end
bounds or nearer,
what's old soldier in,
it's an estimated.
He also estimated that the same kind of
internal repression in Maoist China cost
100 million lives.
And so you can imagine that the genuine
historical figures,
again,
are subject to dispute,
but somewhere between 50 and 100 million
people.
And one of the things that's really
surprising to me and that that I think
is absolutely reprehensible,
absolutely reprehensible,
is the fact that this is not widespread
knowledge among students in the west,
any of this.
And it's because your education,
your historical education,
if you started to describe it as
appalling,
you would barely scratch the surface.
These were the most important events of
the 20th century and they're barely
covered at all in standard historical
curriculum.
You know,
something I would presume about World
War II and about the terrible situation
in Nazi Germany and the death of 6
million Gypsies and Jews and homosexuals
in the concentration camps in Nazi
Germany.
But my experience with students has been
that none of them know anything about
what happened as a consequence of the
repression of the radical left in the
20th century.
And I believe the reason for that is
that the communist system had extensive
networks of admirers in the west,
especially among intellectuals and still
in fact does,
which is also equally reprehensible.
Um,
and I believe the,
one of the consequences of that is that
this element of history has been under,
uh,
under,
what would you say under examined and
certainly very little attention has been
brought to it in the public school
curricula.
And there's absolutely no excuse for
that.
It was the worst thing that happened in
the 20th century.
And that's really saying something
because the 20th century was about as
bad as it gets.
And so,
and the fact that these,
these massive,
these deaths on massive scale occurred,
and the fact that we don't know that
deep inside our bones is,
is,
is a testament to the absolute rot of
the education system.